so this week on the website we reviewed
a bunch of coffee brewing equipment uh
carissa bell from the gadget lab took a
look at five different manual coffee
brewing machines and her favorite of all
of those was this one the aeropress
which is also matt honan's favorite oh
it's an aeropress yeah i thought it was
something totally different
um it's not my favorite actually okay
but i agreed with her logic and i and i
i understood why she why it is her
favorite and for very many people it is
their favorite and you use it a lot oh i
use it all the time and you have your
own technique i do i do i think one of
the interesting things about the
aeropress is you can really dial in
something that you like and a lot of
people have various ways to do it
certainly youtube backs up that claim
yeah youtube you can spend hours on
youtube watching aeropress videos like
the the directions on the box are a
starting point okay so i have come to
understand that your aeropress technique
is believed by you and a few other
people who are close to you to be the
best aeropress it's good it's quite good
yeah i mean i use what's called the
inverted method which is basically you
just
use the thing upside down okay i can't
wait to see this yeah it's cool you want
to demo it for us sure so let's start
off uh so when you're making coffee as
everyone knows
uh the most important thing is to have
freshly roasted beans these are roasted
on march 7th so they're a little bit
older than i normally would but for the
purposes of just this video that's three
weeks right now
i'm sorry
um okay so you want something that's two
weeks or less two weeks is great i mean
actually anything within a month it
should be fine okay but you know freshly
roasted beans as long as you have a
coffee locker
right you need a coffee locker
don't get me started what happens if you
don't have a coffee oh my god and then
you've got a little drug scale yeah so i
think this is actually designed for
something other than coffee but we're
going to use it it's a gram scale that
will measure to a tenth of a gram and uh
i'm going to weigh out 15 grams of beans
here
so what are you shooting for a cup
i'm gonna make eight ounces yeah eight
ounces 16 grams a little bit a little
bit over here
there we go
that should be right at 15.
and next we're going to use uh
this hario
manual bur grinder uh a burr grinder
unlike a blade do you want to explain
this to the people yes sure uh well a
blade grinder will
basically reduce your coffee beans to a
fine dust very quickly and it's
inconsistent you'll have whole beans and
dusty
coffee in there this
produces an even pulverization
and you know you just do what he's doing
it kind of goes everywhere but that's
sort of the flavor of it
you could pick up one of these for
30 35 bucks on amazon or you can get a
full electric version that does
essentially the same thing without the
elbow grease for spend thousands yeah
you really can but the sweet spot for a
good one in the electric range is
between like 150 and 250 dollars
but this is all you need
plus you can take it on the road
and he's grinding
all right how are you doing there i'm
almost finished
i'm almost finished okay i'm finished
all right and that's easy and so
what we've got here is we've got uh
some
grounds that are probably a little bit
thicker than what you would normally use
a little bit coarser than what you would
use for a pour over but not so coarse
not nearly as coarse as a french press
okay
you just referred to this machine as a
french press
no i'm saying you would they're not as
thick as you would oh
yeah not a stick this is an aeropress so
what's the difference between this and a
french press um a french press this is
using
there's a couple things going into play
here uh and one of them is pressure it's
not just the hot water just the pressure
we're going to flip this over in a
minute and push down and it's going to
be using air pressure to similar to the
way that you make espresso um how
espresso relies on air pressure a french
press you're just it's just filtering
the coffee and uh so
you know you put the grounds in there
you let them sit for four minutes and
then you push down the filter
and you actually still usually get
sediment in there this because it has a
paper filter
which we have rinsed very important
rinse the paper filter first
gets the paper flavor out of there just
like a jacuzzi
just like a jacuzzi yeah you don't get
any um
you don't get any sediment in your
coffee with an aeropress like you do
with a french press okay cool
all right so now if we only had hot
water
pour
this in
and we're now timing it on your phone
yeah timer running for a minute and a
half okay
oh hey it's been one minute and 30
seconds awesome so now i'm gonna try and
do this
seated it's gonna be harder i'm gonna do
that oh you're kidding me and now we're
just gonna push down nice long slow so
it's already running through it's
already running through and the pressure
is pushing it through faster and like
the key here is to push but slowly okay
so you're not really just like plunging
it
yeah you don't want to like go on there
like
full speed and you know but this is
something that like grandma could do
right oh yeah easily easily easily
and if you do the whole thing right like
the push should
take a little bit yeah there is some air
coming out there now the push should
take less than a minute and this is
what's so great about the aeropress once
you finish with this
so we've got delicious coffee here
this is one of the many things that's so
great about the aeropress got some
delicious coffee here
well thank you i made a mess
but the aeropress is not messy you can
just take this off
and the little you've got a little puck
here of grounds and it'll just pop right
off in the trash can
you can just wipe this with a with a
damp cloth
so it's great for like hotel rooms it's
fantastic i travel with mine all the
time
he does i've seen him
this is lovely thank you matt cheers
you smell the uh
get a little bit of that
yeah some of that yeah
a little grassy
i like it
lovely
so uh what is this lovely device you've
got here this is the we think smart body
analyzer it's a scale that will tell you
not just how much you weigh but how much
body fat you've got oh awesome bring it
on yeah
so this is this is part of like um this
is one of those gadgets that people are
getting into because they're more
interested in learning just about the
basics they want to get more into yeah
quantifying all of the different pieces
of their their body for different
reasons right and so this scale you may
have seen the last uh we think scale
this is sort of similar it it takes
measurements every day
and we'll send them to an app that's on
your phone uh and in this case what it's
taking it it'll take your
weight your heart rate which is new oh
it measures that through your feet it
measures that through your feet it
measures the air quality in your room
um and it's it's basically designed to
help you kind of know even more than the
last one did and you can do things in
the app like set weight loss goals and
it will try and help you reach those
that's very cool what does air quality
tell you
i think the idea is if you have too much
co2 in your room um
it's it's it's bad
okay so it'll
alert you to that yes all right it'll
let you know
does it tweet your weight
you can set up things like that uh i
think it's uh dennis crowley who sort of
famously tweets his weight all the time
yeah but he does something it doesn't
have to and like if you reach a goal
like i lost i i lost two pounds last
week mike oh congratulations thank you
that was my goal and i could have
tweeted that goal but i opted not to
right i think most people would probably
opt not to yeah although you know they
do say that if you publicly declare uh
an intention then you're more likely to
follow through on that intention burn
the ships that's right that's right so
it's something like uh it's something
that some people might be interested in
if they want to get like super serious
and they need the extra motivation right
but for most people public shamings
um so what's the app experience like the
app is really great uh the app uh and if
you have other if you're in the
we things ecosystem it will pull other
things in as well uh you can it can not
only does it does it track the stuff
coming from the scale if you've got the
wii things blood pressure monitor it'll
pull that data in as well and you can
link it up with run keeper
so it which is you know a lot of people
may have that on their phone anyway and
uh so it'll really try and give you a
whole picture of your health so there
are other companies that make sort of um
body monitoring devices like fitbit
makes its own scale
also aria i believe it is yeah that
works with the with the fitbit clip
uh so what does this work with on on
weaving's side well i you one would have
to assume that it's going to come
that it's going to work with the
the we think activity monitor that we
saw at ces that's going to be coming out
that's a really nice sd card size
yeah
it's it's it's bigger than sd card but
tiny like really really small
goes in your pocket but and as i said it
works with the blood pressure monitor uh
and
i'm not sure if there are other devices
it works with as well but it certainly
is going to work with those too cool
that's all the time we have for this
week so we're going to go weigh
ourselves and drink a lot of coffee and
we'll see you next week on the gadget
lab